uh uh peter
uh we we've seen press conferences and
and you know there's all sorts of tells
and
the the deep breath by sean mcvay
like man how am i gonna answer this
question without saying what i really
think about jared goff
how am i going to answer this question
that i knew was coming
yeah i still can't figure it out i've
been thinking about it for two days
oh
god hey uh uh who
that's yeah you know any time it starts
with whoo you you know what comes next
it's gonna be entertaining but maybe all
not not that all all enlightening uh hey
and i appreciate that these coaches and
general managers are doing media
availability
on their own they otherwise would be
doing it at the combine it would be a
much more organic and realistic
background than whatever they they they
put together on photoshop and put behind
mcvay but yeah
look
they got rid of jared goff and he was
far more candid about jared goff before
he traded him you'd think now he'd take
the gloves off i mean they were throwing
the guy under the bus repeatedly
late last year it was stunning the stuff
sean mcvay was saying about jared goff
i'm surprised that all of a sudden he's
being guarded with his words
i mean why would he
why would he say for instance let's just
say there's not again nothing
nothing at this point he gains nothing
by it he gains nothing by it so in other
words
you know you ca and plus plus
i believe that sean mcvay
feels bad
about what happened
because remember mike
right after he signed his own
ridiculously large extension he approved
well-nigh pushed
to be joined at the hip with jared goff
he cost stan cronky
a crapload of money you know that wasn't
particularly well spent as we've looked
at the last two years okay but so he he
he spent a huge amount of money
and now he brings in another quarterback
and it and i'm just saying
that
he better be right with stafford
because if he's not right with stafford
the next quarterback he goes to stan
cronky and says oh we need uh three
number ones
whatever we need this to go get this
quarterback and if we get him oh there's
the final piece
cronky is going to look at him being the
businessman that he is and says
are you really the man i thought you
were
honestly
and so look
and and they are not there yet they are
not close to being there because i
believe you believe we all believe that
matthew stafford's going to be really
good with the rams so i don't think it's
going to come to that but all i'm saying
is
it better not come to that
peter that is a great point and when you
throw on top of it the money they gave
to todd gurley a year earlier
millions and millions millions upon
millions of stan kroenke's money gone
forever and something occurred to me
as you were making that excellent point
when they did the trade and it's not
official yet it could still in theory
fall apart but it likely won't most
likely undoubtedly won't
the matthew stafford for jared goff two
ones and a three going to the lions
you know that transaction allowed the
rams to gloss over
the brock osweiler hot potato element of
that deal and i spoke to a general
manager right after that deal was leaked
announced whatever and we came to a
loose conclusion that it was a one and a
three for stafford
and a one
given up to the lions to take the awful
jared goff contract off the books and by
doing it in one transaction
it wasn't as obvious as the osweiler
deal right it's okay well matthew
stafford two ones and a three franchise
quarterback i wonder how much of that
was aimed at keeping stan kroenke from
figuring out that they gave up a first
round pick to get that horrible contract
off the books
well look mike you know when i look at
this trade i look at it a little bit
differently
because look brad holmes
is not doing that trade the new general
manager of the lions
he's not doing that trade
if he believes that jared goff is
unfixable
he just i believe he just would not have
done it he would have tr he might have
traded matthew stafford to the rams but
he would have taken one of his other
players that he has drafted there as a
director of college scouting
but
he believes and i'm told dan campbell
has watched tape
and also believes that jared goff is
fixable and so why not take
a couple of years
and take this quarterback
and see if you can fix him
and at the end of a couple of years if
you can't you basically say no harm no
foul we gave it a go and we got two ones
out of it so
that is a risk well worth taking
just amazing to think that
holmes with the rams with les snead is
the gm sean mcveigh is the head coach
there would be such a different
viewpoint on jared goff where the rams
couldn't wait to get rid of him after
the season ended and that holmes looks
at him as a guy that they welcomed to
detroit now it's not like they were
going to convince matthew stafford to
stick around he was ready to go and they
let him go i mean stafford would be
right there with russell wilson and
deshaun watson now if the lions hadn't
been so willing to accommodate his
request to get out of detroit after 12
seasons but uh you know i guess if
you're not going to have stafford at
least goff is a known entity and holmes
has seen
the best of what goff can do and maybe
they can get something better you got to
have a running game you got to have a
run and get you got to have you don't
necessarily have to have todd gurley but
without todd gurley or without todd
gurley of 2017 and most of 2018 it was a
different jared goff and i think if the
lions can put that around goff they're
going to need some receivers they're
going to need the running back they need
to keep kenny gallaudet they're going to
need to fix figure something out but
they they uh they could they could be
better than we think they will be and
better than they've been in recent years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports